지호님이 온 지가 얼마나 됐죠?
1년 정도 된 거죠.
그러면 딱 할 때랑 아다리가 맞네.
내가 100만을 찍으면 나가야겠다고 생각했을 때가 1년 전인데
그때랑 묘하게 아다리가 맞네요?
정말 묘하네요.
하필 또 그 시점에 시장님이 또 나가셨고
그러니까 제가 위험한 발언을 하니까 눈이...
아니야x3
잘 모르겠는데 똑같거든요, 사실.
네, 똑같죠.
모든 게 똑같아요.
헤어스타일, 안경 바뀌었어요?
네, 똑같죠.
다 똑같아.
근데 철학이 느껴져.
원래 그런 거 아니겠습니까?
나만 그런가?
왜 그런 거야?
나는 이제 이 헤어스타일도 철학이 느껴지고
우리 그 뭐죠? 얼평쇼?
말도 안 된다고 생각해.
세상이 이제 재평가를 하는구나.
그렇죠, 이제서야 좀 본질 가치를 찾은 것 같고.
다시 한 번 더 해야겠네, 얼평쇼.
얼평쇼 하면 아마 저스티스 님도 굉장히
이 필터가 돼서 굉장히 올라갈 수 있어요.
그렇죠, 심혜어 언급은 안 했겠죠?
블록피쉬야 뭐야, 그건 말도 안 되는 거야, 사실.
그전엔 몰라뵜다고.
농담, 그 정도는 아니에요.
자, 그러면 이제 자기소개를 한 번씩 부탁드리겠습니다.
안녕하세요.
구심혜어 현 김선태, 충주의 왕이었던
하지만 지금은 폐휘된 김선태라고 합니다.
반갑습니다.
김블롬 님 오셨고.
네, 안녕하세요.
여행하는 백수, 지금 진짜 백수 빤히 못 드립니다.
아, 백수예요?
저는 백수라는 게 좋더라고요.
진짜 백수처럼 살아요.
지금 요즘에 하는 거 딱히 없어요?
편집하고 편집 끝나면 어제도 그냥 막 퍼크 치고
오버워치 하고, 오버워치 신캐 나와서 재밌더라고요.
포커는 온라인으로?
아니요, 그냥 가서.
퍼크 같은데?
네, 퍼크 가서 하고.
재밌어요, 그거?
맛 들려가지고.
이러다 말아요, 또.
사설이네요?
뭔 사설이야, 미친놈아.
국립은 아니잖아.
말이 이상하잖아.
사설은 맞는데 이제 돈이 안 걸렸지.
국립으로 누가 해.
국립은 아니잖아.
국립 있어, 강원랜드.
그러네, 국립이 있구나.
아마 홀더는 없을 건데, 아무튼.
나라에서 허락한 유일한 도망이 있어요.
퍼크 가서 하면 상금이 있어서 이렇게 하는 건가?
상금은 없고 포인트를 줘서 그걸로 또 들어가던가 하고.
아, 나 들었어, 그 포인트를 모으면
전국에 있는 대회에 참전할 수 있는 권한이 생겨서
또 더 큰 대회에 나갈 수 있고,
더 큰 대회, 그러면 이제 그런 데는 상금이 있을 거야.
그리고 타이틀도 생기고 하면 진짜 너무 잘하면 스폰서가 붙을 수도 있고,
스폰서가 붙으면 여행 경비 대주고,
외국에 있는 대회에 나갈 수 있고,
점점 큰 무대로 갈 수 있는,
그게 판이니까.
판이 깔리는 거지.
아니, 그래서 2년 전에 영상 찾아보니까 침투비에 있더라고요.
그 임요한 선생님 모셔가지고.
맞습니다.
오셨어요.
제가 그걸로 또 좀 배우고.
그 처음 임무는 어떻게 했어요?
서출구라고 같이 피해게임했던 친구 있는데,
그 친구가 알려주고.
여행 유튜버?
래퍼, 래퍼.
랩 래퍼입니다.
경?
아니요, 랩 그냥 래퍼.
래퍼만 하세요?
순수 래퍼.
요즘은 서바이벌을 좀 더 하긴 하는데,
랩 조금 잘 안 하고.
근데 너무 실례인데, 비슷한 이름 있지 않아요?
서출구?
아닌가?
아, 죄송합니다.
누가 있지?
어, 약간 있는 것 같은데?
잠깐만.
입구?
서재로?
그런가 보다.
서재로요?
그러네.
서재로.
로가.
길로자 느낌이 나잖아.
서재로 씨가 어떻게 보면 요즘 여행 유튜버 중에서 거의 1항이라서.
아, 그래.
제일 잘 나가는 분이라서.
난 경 하는 줄 알았어.
헷갈릴 수 있죠.
요즘 경 하는 사람 많아.
아, 맞아.
그래서 그 서출구 님이 알려주셔서 해봤는데,
아, 맞았다.
원래 워낙 게임 좋아하고.
취미는 잘할 필요 없으니까.
잘 못하는데 그냥 재미 삼아 하고 있고.
오버치도 그렇고.
그렇구나.
근데 사실 두 분이 침둥에는 한 번씩 나오셨는데,
라이브는 진짜 오랜만에 오신 것 같아요.
몇 년 됐죠?
네.
꽤 오래 됐죠.
저는 마지막에 에브민스 선생님이랑 했던 것 같은데.
알파고랑 한 거 아니에요?
알파고인가?
알파고 님이 최근일 거예요.
아, 그거 맞네. 맞네.
알파고 님 그때 소개시켜줘서.
빠니보틀 님이 소개해주는 사람이 은근히 많아요.
추천이라고 해야 될까?
저는 삼국지에서 재야에 묻힌 고수들.
갈굴해주는 약간 기분 좋더라고요.
사실 재야도 아니야.
재야도 아닌데.
제 기준 재야예요.
이미 유명한데.
내가 모르는 사람한테 추천을 해주는 느낌.
약간 매칭을 해주는 느낌.
그렇지 않아요?
알파고도 제가 같이 여행하면서 굉장히 천재적인 면모.
제 옆에 또 천재 두 분이 앉아계시지만.
좀 중동적으로 천재여서.
나 본인도 침티부를 다 하고 싶어 했어요.
아, 니지가.
내가 한 번 얘기해보겠다.
그래서 얘기했는데,
사실 처음에는 항상 반응이 원래 말씀 드리면 시큰둥이하시니까.
아니, 저는 진짜 관심을 표하는 건데 이래요.
아, 그래요?
이렇게 하니까 관심이 없어 보이는.
나는.
나 관심이 없어 보이는.
관심 없으면 아, 예.
이렇게 하는데.
관심.
아, 그래요?
근데 이게 좀 관심 없다고 생각나봐.
침드렁, 침드렁.
아까도 인사하는데 왜 이렇게 좀 자기적인 것 같다고.
맞아요, 맞아요.
안 반가운 것 같다고 좀.
아, 요즘 너무 바쁘시죠.
기계가 말씀하신 줄 알고.
내가 들어가자마자.
야, 요즘 많이 바쁘시죠.
이게 알파고지.
어려운 걸음을.
이게 진짜 알파고지.
어려운 걸음을 해주셨어요.
그거 아세요?
침착맨 님 특.
눈도 안 마주침.
눈도 안 봐.
눈도 안 보고 그냥 허공했다가.
제가 멀티태스킹이 안 돼.
멀티태스킹에서.
눈을 마주치면 걷다가 부딪쳐요.
그럼 또 패잖아요.
그래서 패를 끼칠 수 없기 때문에.
근황 같은 거를 한 번 얘기해 주시는데.
아까 본 포커 편집하고.
김선태 님은?
저는 뭐 좀 바쁘게 살고 있죠.
근데 뭐 바쁜 게.
다른 게 바쁜 게 아니라 그냥 혼자 바쁜 것 같아요.
새로 나와서 유튜브를 하려다 보니까.
어렵더라고요, 생각보다.
챙길 것도 많고.
직원분 도움도 이제 한 분을 뽑아가지고.
도움도 받고 있는데.
그러고 있습니다.
뭐가 제일 어려워요?
회사를 차렸잖아요, 어쨌든.
1인 법인이긴 한데.
구멍가게를 하나 차려가지고.
직원분을 뽑았는데.
직원분을 제가 이제.
케어를 해야 되는 거잖아요, 계속.
그러니까 두 배로 더 힘든 상황이에요.
아, 직원 문제다?
아니 아니, 직원분이 되게 좋으신데.
같이 오셨는데.
아, 너무 잘해주시는데.
말씀 중에 죄송한데 밥 좀 먹어도 돼요?
밥을 먹는다고요?
아니 근데 식사를 하셨다고.
아, 저 먹고 왔습니다.
저는 안 먹어요.
전 같이 먹으려고 했는데.
지금 이게 세 개가 준비가 돼 있거든요.
안 드시죠?
네.
먹고 싶은 말씀하세요.
한 입 찬스 드릴게요.
괜찮습니다.
충주시 홍구맨으로 활동을 하시다가.
아.
나오셨어요.
그때 이제 그런 말씀을 하셨던 것 같아요, 나오면서.
백만은 해놓고 나가고 싶다.
맞습니다.
그 얘기를 선언하셨는데.
우리 사적으로 했었나?
공적으로 했었나요?
공적으로 했어요.
공적으로 했었어요.
왜냐면 이게 이거를.
백만은 해놓고 가야지 내 업무 일을 다 한 거고.
인수인계도 좀 제대로 하고 가고 싶고.
그런 얘기를 했거든요.
맞아요.
백만 됐나요?
90 몇 만 아니었나요?
97만 정도로 알고 있었는데.
97.5인가, 8까지 갔었는데.
그 정도면 저는 이제.
일을 다 안 했네.
음.
저는 그렇게 생각합니다.
반올림이라는 개념도 있고.
꼭 그거를 또 숫자가 중요한가.
거의 뭐 100이니까.
사실 모든 게 정확하게 하려고 하면은.
다 오차가 있기 마련인데.
그 정도 오차는 백만으로 볼 숫자.
여백임이.
그렇죠.
한두 끗도 없죠.
그래서 이제 그거를 좀.
그 정도에서 마무리를 해야겠다고 생각을 했고.
그런 것도 있어요.
제가 백만 달성하고 나오면.
그 다음 직원부터는 목표가 하나도 없잖아요.
왜냐면 제가 골드까지 다 먹고 나가면.
아, 숙제를 주고 나갔다.
그렇죠.
그럼 뭐.
할 거리를 남겼다.
할 거리를 남겨서.
그렇죠.
백만 달면은.
컨텐츠 하나 할 수 있으니까.
그러니까 그거예요.
쩌리를 해주는 거예요 제가.
와우에서 쩌리를 해줘요.
쩌리를 해줘요.
쩌리를 해줘.
그러면 간당까지 딱 해놓는 거예요.
그리고 이거는 너가 막 봐라.
아.
그래서.
배려하네.
그렇죠.
혼자 필드에서 이제 막.
잡아먹어 해가지고.
업을 할 수 있게.
아, 물고기 잡는 법을 또 알려주는.
그렇죠.
게다가 저는 인수인계를.
1년 동안 했습니다.
1년 동안 했다고 1년 동안.
반응이.
반응이 좀 너무.
아 밥이.
아니 뭐 그렇게 뭐.
임팩트 있는 얘기 없었잖아.
아 그래요?
1수인계 1년 했다는 게.
네네네.
막 그렇게 눈을 마주치면서 들어야 될 건 아니잖아.
아 알겠습니다.
아까 들어올 때.
아 요즘 너무 바쁘세요.
이거 여기서.
피해의식이 좀 생긴 것 같아.
아닙니다.
저 사람은 진심이었다.
피해다.
내년안이다.
아 자꾸 보게 되네요.
그럼 1년 전부터 그런 생각을 했었다는 거잖아요.
왜냐면 어쨌든 제가 유튜브를 평생 할 수가 없잖아요.
제가 나이가 이제 40이고.
아.
아니 아니야.
그거는 잘못된 생각인 것 같아요.
40이었어요.
나이가 중요한 건 아닌 것 같은데 나는.
너가 얼마나 오래 했냐가 중요하지.
뭐 평생까지는 아니어도 꽤 할 수 있지 않을까?
아니 근데 실제로 유튜브를 시작할 때.
저랑 상담을 굉장히 많이 했어요.
거의 전화로.
예 전화로 해서.
진로에 대한 얘기하면서 제가 막 해가지고.
아니 유튜브 해라.
막 그러더라고요.
아 내가 하면은 뭐.
10만, 20만 할 수 있겠지 이런.
얘기하면서.
맞아 이렇게.
저한테 1년이 얼마 버냐고 그냥.
물어봐가지고.
대접 물어봤어.
아니 그냥 뭐 이 정도 버는데.
너가 하면은.
나랑 비슷하거나 뭐 못 해도.
뭐 한 7, 80%지 않을까 해가지고 막.
쟤 뭐 다 보내주고.
이것저것 자료.
했는데.
제가 그랬거든요.
뭐 10만, 20만 얘기하려고.
아 뭐 50만은.
너가 하면은 기본으로 되지.
이렇게 얘기했는데 저도.
이 정도까지 막은 예상.
사실 아무도 예상 못 해서.
맞아요.
저도 못 했어요.
제 생각엔 이제 뭐 브랜드 파워도 있겠지만은.
아다리가 좀 잘 맞았던 것 같아요.
밈화된 것도 있고.
그 밈화될 때 딱 그게 나오니까.
관심이 최고조에 올라왔을 때.
딱 한 거.
여기 있습니다.
이게 아다리가 좀 맞았던 것 같아요.
원래도 좀 화제의 인물이고.
브랜드 가치가 굉장히 높았던 인물이지만.
그런 얘기도 있었어요.
뭐 청와대에서 뭐 러브콜을 보냈다.
근데 이런 게 이게 사실이냐 아니냐.
뭐 이런 얘기도 있고.
청와대 같은 경우는.
자리를 정해서 제의를 받은 게 아니고.
가볍게?
네.
혹시 의사가 있는지.
의향은 있냐?
네.
음.
왜냐면 그 전에 뭐 템퍼링이 있었던 것도 아니고.
제가 나가기로 결정한 다음에 이제.
음.
이렇게 한 번 면담을 했던 거고.
마치 야인이 됐으니까 한 번 물어본 거로.
맞습니다.
근데 그런 면담은 또 몇 군데가 있었어요.
사실 소속사 쪽에서도 연락이 왔었었고.
음.
어떻게 보면 길이 좀 열려있는 상황이었어요.
그때 되게 다양하게.
회사에서도 연락이 왔었고.
지금 채팅창에 뭐 찔러만 본 거라고 하는데.
찔러만 본 건 아니죠.
의향을 물어보고 그 다음 얘기를 해야 되는데.
그렇죠.
그 선에서 이제 거절을 했으니까.
네.
진행이 안 됐다는 얘기겠죠?
네네네.
그리고 왜 찔러만 보는 게 쉽지 않은 게.
만약에 찔러만 봤는데.
그 사람 덥석 한다 그러면 또.
그것도 골치 아파서.
그냥 찔러만 보기는 쉽지 않을 거예요.
음.
그런 건 없을 거고.
그럴 때는 이제 물고기가 이렇게 물잖아요.
그 덥석 물잖아요.
잘 안 뜯어지잖아요.
그걸 뜯어버리더라고요.
하하하하하하.
여기까지.
아 예.
사실 이게 유튜버를 그냥 하라고 하는 게 쉽지 않거든요.
했다가 망하는 사람도 꽤 많아서.
맞아요.
사실 김선태한테는 좀 쉬웠죠.
왜냐면 이 친구도 하면은 금방 할 것 같다.
근데 진짜 50만 정도 제가 예상했거든요.
음.
아득히 예상을 벗어났죠.
범죄를.
나는 50만 예상한 것도 좀 대단하다고 봐요.
저도 과하게 생각했다고 생각해요.
왜냐하면 지금이야 뭐 100만 되고 막 이렇게 하니까 그러는데.
그때 당시에 이게 진짜 어떻게 될지 모르겠는데.
그걸 50만까지 봤다는 거는 나름.
고평가인 거죠.
고평가도 있는데.
응.
근데 보는 눈이 있는 거지.
음.
제 기준은 그건 거 같아요.
같이 여행 갔을 때 불량 걱정 안 하게 만드는 사람들이 있거든요.
음.
뭐 그게 알파고였고.
아하.
그게 이제 김선태였고 그런 게 있기 때문에.
저는 개인적으로 초반에 한 10만 20만 되고.
한 달 두 달 세 달 가면 세 달 정도에 한 30만 정도 될까라고 생각을 했었어요.
음.
예상은.
근데 이제 너무 빨리 잘 돼가지고 상상을 못 했죠.
음.
그럼 좀 당황스러우면서 부담도 될 거 같은데.
어우 잠도 못 잤습니다.
초반에는.
걱정이 많이 돼가지고.
처음엔 기분 좋았는데 시간이 지나면서 안 멈추고 계속 올라가니까.
그쵸.
제 거만 잘 되면 상관이 없는데 제 것이 잘 되면서 충주시가 좀 내려갔었어요 그때.
저희 원래 채널이.
근데 왜 충주시를 욕했는지 모르겠어.
사람들이 가만히 봐도.
가슴 아픈 게 막 이랬어.
나는 충주시를 보려고 김선태를 보려고 구독한 거였어.
그래서 막 끊는대.
근데 그냥 조용히 끊지.
그러면 왜.
그러니까 맞아.
댓글을 왜 다닌 거야 어떻게.
그러니까 왜 기분 나쁘게 하려고 왜 받는 거야.
왜 굳이.
나는 약간 그런.
아무래도 생산자 입장이니까.
좀 이임이 되더라고 충주시 쪽에.
맞아요 맞아요.
아니 근데 그런 댓글이 많잖아요 뭐.
막 약간 협박하면서 뭐 하네 구독 취소합니다 그러는데.
우리가 보통 구독 취소를 할 수는 있지.
근데 그냥 조용히 하는 게 많잖아.
근데 굳이 굳이 남기는 거는 이걸 봐줘.
알아봐달라는.
너가 이래서 너가 마음에 안 들어오니까.
알아봐달라는 거지.
그거 그게 의도가 악하지는 않을 거예요.
김선태를 응원하는 느낌으로 좀 한 거였을 텐데.
근데 이제 그게 M은 스플래시가 충주시에 들어가는 거지.
맞아요.
그래서 처음에는 맞다고 생각했어요 떨어지는 게.
개인 비중이 높았으니까 나가니까 이제 팬들이 좀 나가겠구나라고 생각을 해서.
처음에는 뭐 이 정도 받을 수 있지.
그렇지.
충분히 있을 수 있는 일이야.
근데 막 20만 이상 빠지니까.
너무 많이 빠졌어.
그거는 좀 그러니까 저도 충주시가 잘 됐으면 좋겠거든요 진짜로.
제 이후에 망하는 걸 절대 보고 싶지 않아서.
그렇지 당연히 그렇지.
진짜 잘 됐으면 좋겠고 응원하고 있습니다 항상.
지호 주무관님 뭐 이렇게 이렇게 했잖아요.
들어오게 된 거는 유튜브판에 들어오게 된 거는 본인이 인원이 너무 부족해서 좀 요청을 한 거예요.
아니면 뭐 자연스럽게 충주시에 좀 지원을 해 주는 거예요.
뭐 어떤 케이스였어요?
그때 뭐냐면 원래 진짜 1인으로 하다가 팀이 만들어지게 된 거예요.
팀이 만들어지게 된 계기는 어쨌든 이걸 시스템화해야 된다.
우리 금병형처럼.
이게 혼자만 할 수 있는 게 아니고.
우리 금병형.
우리 금병형처럼.
아 우리 금병형처럼.
체계가 갖춰져야 이 사람이 나가도 이제 뭔가 굴러갈 수 있겠다.
그래서 이제 팀원을 뽑고 후임자 개념으로 이제 뽑아왔던 거죠.
어떻게 보면 그때부터 염두를 해왔던 거긴 하죠.
그러니까 팀이 만들어진 건 요청이 있었어요?
혼자 하기에는 이제 그 채널 규모가 너무 커졌으니까 지원이 필요하다.
그건 아니고 시장님이 만들어주셨습니다.
시장님이 어쨌든 이제 저희가 팀 정돈 돼야 된다라고 생각을 해서 만들어주셨고.
그래서 이제 제가 그때 과분하게 이제 팀장이 됐고.
근데 그거는 이제 본인의 의사가 있는 거야 아니면 그냥 들어가는 거야 그냥?
그걸 모르겠어요.
본인의 의사가 딱 들어가는 건지 아니면 그냥 배정을 해 주는 건지.
그 인원은 제가 좀 스카우트를 해왔습니다.
그러니까 원래는 그게 인사팀 권한이에요.
근데 직무가 좀 특별하잖아요.
특이하잖아요.
그래서 이제 그 특이한 직무이기 때문에 좀 어떻게 뭐 추천을 했던 거죠.
이 친구가 괜찮을 것 같다 이렇게.
그거를 검토해 달라니까 아 오케이 알았다.
뭐 본인의 뭐 이렇게 팀에서 요청도 있고 하니까 인사팀에서 오케이 자 해줄게 약간 이런 느낌?
많이 도와주셨죠.
왜냐면 그걸 또 이제 외권으로 생각할 수도 있거든요.
그래서 지금 좀 약간 조심스러운 것 같은데.
절차를 밟았다는 거지.
밟았죠.
이 사람을 해주세요 이게 아니고 이 사람을 추천합니다.
그런 느낌이라고 보는 게 좋겠죠.
혹시 이 분을 제가 추천해도 혹시 기분 나쁘실 수 있지만 혹시 제가 한번 여쭤봐도 될까요?
여쭤볼 수 있는.
특혜도 아니야.
특혜라고 하면 좀 여쭤볼 수 있는 기회를 한번 제공받아도 될까요라고.
그렇죠 그렇죠 군대는 한번 만나뵈도 될까요?
이렇게 해서 이제 추천을 해드렸던 거죠.
너무 그러니까 비꼬는 것 같다.
아니야 아니야.
아유 제가 아무것도 안 되지만.
쇳내가.
비루하고 미쳐난 쇳내가 흙바닥 먹으면서 잠깐 100년 만에 고개 한번 들고 여쭈어 봅니다.
한번요 여쭙습니다.
여쭙습니다.
지렁이만 먹는 게.
하당 한 권을 감히 윗공기 마시면서 한번 여쭈어 봅니다.
감히 고개를 쳐들고.
지금 책상 밑에 계속 두 손이 공손히 모아지고 있어서.
진짠가 봐 진짜.
근데 그 지호님을 한 이유가 있었어요?
지호가 일단 눈에 광기가 있었어요.
옛날에 시리즈 같은 걸 촬영해 봤었는데 그때 느꼈습니다.
아 얘가 좀 똘끼가 있고 얘가 거침이 없구나.
아 삭수가 보인다.
유튜브 할 때 뭐 저희 입장에서는 뭔가 이게 툭툭 던져주는 쪽이 좋잖아요.
솔직하게.
근데 그 친구가 좀 솔직하게 좀 해주는 스타일.
아 이 친구 정도면 괜찮지 않을까?
라고 생각을 했었던 것 같아요.
잘 발굴했네요 그러면.
매력도 있고.
지호님이 온 지가 얼마나 됐죠? 그 팀에?
제가 나올 때.
1년 정도 된 거죠.
그러면 딱 그 할 때랑 아다리가 맞네.
아 내가 100만을 찍으면 나가야겠다고 생각했을 때가 1년 전인데.
그 때랑 묘하게 아다리가 맞네요.
아 정말 묘하네요.
근데 뭐 그냥 연결돼 있는 건 아니죠.
그냥 모든 일이라는 게 공교로운 경우가 있어.
공교.
이게 참 오해받기 쉬운데 팩트는 팩트니까.
그쵸 그쵸.
그러니까 공교롭게도 1년 전에 100만을 찍으면 나는 인수인계 다 하고 가야겠다였고.
근데 마침 인수인계 할 사람은 1년 전에.
그쵸 그쵸.
왔었고.
그리고 조심스럽게 추천을 한 적이 있었고.
많이 공그렸네요.
그리고 이제 하필 또 그 시점에 시장님이 또 나가셨고.
1년 전에 예정이 돼 있었다?
예정은 아닌데 3선이시기 때문에 뭔가 나가실 것 같아서.
끝이니까 이제.
나 이렇게 눈을 잘 마주시는데 왜 눈을 안 마주신다고 하는 거예요.
갑자기 좀 그러니까 제가 위험한 발언을 하니까 눈을.
아니야 아니야 아니야.
아니 나는.
아니 아까는.
몸까지 돌리시고.
1년 전에 인수인계 준비를 했다고 해서.
아 그다음이 중요하니까.
이게 중요한 거잖아요.
맞아요 맞아요.
아 그렇구나.
공교롭게 그렇게 된 거고.
사실 이제 막연히 생각을 했죠.
제가 언젠가는 이 일을 일단 떠나야 되지 않을까.
언젠가는.
그 생각을 계속하고 있었습니다.
왜 떠나야 된다고 생각을 했어요?
일단.
뭐 순장.
순장 직전에 나온 거지 뭐.
순장.
그것도 이제 무슨 단어.
지금 머릿속에서 단어가 왔다 갔다 할 거야.
공무원이라는 사회에서 뭐 시장님이 굉장히 뭐 큰 영향력은 있겠지만.
압도적이죠.
시청에서 시장님의 위치는 인사권이 있기 때문에.
사실 이제 굉장하죠.
근데 이제 어쨌든 받기 싫게 100%였고.
저 스스로도 이런 생각을 한 적은 있습니다.
내가 여기서 나가면 시청에서 그렇게 과연 싫어할까 이런 생각도 한 적은 있는 것 같아요.
좋아할 수도 있는 거잖아요.
좀 속물 같지만.
승진 자리도 좀 생기는 거고.
제가 이제 팀장 승진을 좀 빨리 했기 때문에.
그거에 대한 좀 반감이 있었던 거잖아요.
사실은 그래서.
나는 그거 충분히 있을 거라고 생각해요.
저도.
이건 자연재해일 거 아니야.
갑자기 그 자리를 한 명이 들은 듯이 나타나가지고.
왜냐면 이거를 근데 사실 진짜 일반 분들을 잘 이해를 못 하실 게.
이게 되게 예민한 문제입니다.
기초 지하체에서 팀장 자리는 사실 이제 졸업이에요.
병장 느낌이에요.
근데 이제 그거를 병장을 쫄병이 먼저 가면 사실 누가 좋아할 수가 없지 않습니까.
그러니까 되게 예민한 생각보다.
그리고 사실.
공무원 아니어도 나는 이해돼요.
이렇게 쭉쭉쭉 연차로 가는 데서 갑자기 이런 뭔가 특별한 케이스가 생겨버리면.
근데 영향을 자기가 받아.
그럼 사실 어렵지.
우리 시장님이 조조면 제가 이제 막 친척 같은 거예요.
친척.
하우돈 같은 거예요.
그러니까 남들이 봤을 때 다른 장수들이 봤을 때는 특히 특혜다 이거.
특혜.
나쁜 놈이다.
근데 조조가 만약에 사후가 됐어 죽었어.
그럼 이제 어떤 일이 벌어질까요.
걔는 이제 좀 그만.
미움을 좀 받겠죠.
그럴 수도 있겠죠.
좀 그런 면이 있었습니다.
그럼 어느 정도 나온 거는 사내 정치적인 선택인 것도 있네.
아니야 아니야.
정치라기보다는.
사내 정치.
전혀 전혀 아니고.
정치라기보다는 본인 눈치가 보인 것 같아요.
제 스스로.
그것도 그렇고 제가 사실 피해를 준 것도 맞아요.
충주시청이 좀 어느 정도.
그런 어떤 사기 측면에서도 그렇고.
아 그렇게까지 이제 생각을.
근데 그건 약간 가스라이팅 당한 건가.
아무래도 이렇게 조직 안 했으면 그런 생각을 할 수도 있잖아.
딴 얘기해야 될 것 같은데 너무 힘들어하는데 지금.
그래서 식은땀이 계속.
예를 들면 선조.
선조가 이순신 장군을.
특진을 3개 특진을 했어.
그러니까 갑자기 특진시키면 우리는 딱 봤을 때.
아 선조의 용인술.
아 대단하다.
이런 파격적인 행보를 보일 수가 있나 근데.
주변에서는.
주변에서 아 뭐 그렇게 다 유성룡까지도 알려.
이렇게까지 하면 안 된다.
그럼 뭐 알았어.
그럼 6개월에 한 번씩 올릴게.
그리고 계속 말도 안 되겠어.
얼마나 부담스러웠을 거야 이순신 장군이.
그리고 이제 다른 공무원분들은.
안 보이는 데서 열심히 일하셨는데.
아 나는 되게 열심히 했는데.
나는 계속 여긴데.
쟤는 유튜브에서 뭐 관짝 들고.
뭐 몇 번 이거 하거든요.
뭐 그런 거 약간 뭐 재밌는 거 몇 개 찍더니.
갑자기 올라가서 이렇게 할 수도 있는 거고.
그렇죠 딸깍.
원래 본인의 어떤 노력에 그거는 자기밖에 모르니까.
그런 거에서 어떤 정당한 시기 질투가 있을 수도 있는 거고.
네 그런 건 있어요.
그러니까 시기 질투보다도.
성과를 내긴 했는데.
공직사회는 성과가 측정이 잘 안 돼요.
왜냐면 제가 제일 고생한 것도 아니고.
솔직히 말하면.
제가 제일 뭐 야근을 많이 한 것도 아니고.
어떻게 보면 공무원 업무가 되게 다양한데.
필수적인 업무들이 있거든요.
근데 그런 거 눈에 안 보여요.
그런 데서 열심히 하시는 분들이 되게 많다.
나 뭔지 알아.
그게 비교가 안 돼.
가사 일이야.
그렇죠.
티가 안 나.
원래 이게 없으면 안 돌아가.
이거예요 이거.
계속 늘상 해야 되는 것들.
근데 티가 잘 안 나지만 진짜 해야 되는 일이고.
그거에 대한 평가를 내릴 때 좀 애매한 거죠 사실.
그거에 대한 그걸 되게 고평가하지 않으니까.
그렇죠.
내부에서는.
왜냐면 진짜 설거지를 진짜 잘할 수도 있잖아요.
보득보득하게.
근데 그거는 티가 안 나는 거야.
그런 거는 언제 티 나냐면 없어지면 티가 나.
그렇죠 그렇죠.
근데 이제 이거는 되게 반짝반짝 돌출된 부분이니까.
아무래도 인목이 집중되고 하니까 좀 그런 거에 대한 좀.
상대적 박탈감?
있어요.
까지 까지 가야 되나?
그런 것들은 있을 거예요.
제가 뭔 얘기하려고 그러냐면.
근래 봤던 김선태 중에서 제일 쩔쩔 매가지고.
어쩔 줄 몰라서.
왜냐면 이 발언이 또 그분들에게 피해를 줄 수도 있으니까 그런 거죠.
본인 얘기면 상관이 없는데.
그리고 저는 이제 뭐 항상 응원하고 있고.
저희 같은 공직자분들을.
초점이 없어 눈에.
자 이제 넘어.
넘어가죠.
넘어가요.
아니 충분히 성심성의껏 답변을 해주셨어요.
네.
아 네네네.
고맙습니다.
약간 궁금한 거.
이것도 곤란할 수도 있는데 약간 궁금한 거.
이것도 곤란할 수도 있어요?
궁금한 아니 곤란할 수 있어요.
그러면 지금 와서 시작한 지 계속 곤란을.
그러면 그냥.
아직 근황이 안 끝났어.
그 대신.
전기의자 같은 거.
그 대신 패스 패스할 수 있어요.
패스할 수 있어요.
알겠어 알겠어.
이제 홍보 그런 일이 공무원 세계에 있어요 원래?
이런 홍보에 관련된 직책이?
원래는 있죠 있기는.
우리가 생각하는 뭐 유튜브나 sns 쪽이 활발하게 된 거는.
그게 아주 주류는 아니고요.
보통 주류는 이제 기자분들 상대하거나 보도자료 쓰거나 이런 쪽이 이제.
사실 지금도 거의가 주류입니다.
그러면은 이제 이렇게 해가지고 되게 성과를 냈어요.
이런 얘기 있잖아.
충주시 어디 있는지도 모르는데 나는 충주시에 대해서 알고 있다.
왜냐하면 유튜브 때문에.
아 저도 저도 그랬어요.
그런 얘기 많고 실제로 저도 대학교가 충주에 있었기 때문에 아는데.
근데 모를 법에 충주랑 청주랑 또 이름도 비슷해가지고 헷갈리기 쉬워요.
전 심지어 친척이 충주 살아가지고 몇 번 가봤는데도 아예 관심이 없었고.
충주가 뭐 어디.
뒤에 위치인지도 몰랐는데 사실 김선태 때문에 알긴 했죠.
그러니까 진짜 홍보가 된 건 사실이에요.
많이 했잖아요.
그러면은 이제 점점 올라간단 말이에요 이제.
계속 올라갔었잖아요 그 급이.
근데 계속 올라가다 보면 유튜브를 계속 할 수 있는 게 아니고 결국은 관리직으로 가야 되잖아요 급이 올라가면.
맞아요.
근데 이제 그 실무를 안 한 상태에서 계속 올라가니까.
그리고 그 급이 올라갔을 때 그 업무를 맡기면은 과연 이 사람이 할 수 있느냐는 생각이 들면서.
아 내가 못 올라가겠다는 생각을 할 것 같거든.
패스권 써 빨리.
아 나는 그 생각을 했어.
맞아요.
그러니까 자기를 생각했어도 내가 지금 실무에서 점점 동떨어지는 일을 하고 있는데.
왜냐하면 공무원 세계는 대부분이 나라를 실무로 관리를 하는 거를 하는 건데.
이거는 사실 어떤 생산적인 일이라 보다는 이미지 메이킹을 하는 거잖아 그렇잖아.
그러니까 굉장히 중요한 역할이지만.
정확합니다.
되게 필요한 건데 근데 이제 실제로 나라를 운영하는 일은 아니니까 결국은 근데 올라가면 관리직은 해야 돼.
그럼 내가 안 하던 일을 결국은 해야 되는데 갑자기 덜컥 맞으면 모르잖아.
서서히 일을 배워가면서 올라가요.
그렇죠 그렇죠.
거기에 대한 고민이 있었을 것 같다는 거예요.
야 근데 진짜.
통찰력이?
아니 그냥 그 당연한 생각 아니야?
진짜 너무 통찰력이 뛰어나셔가지고 내부 게시판인 줄 알았어요.
아 진짜 내부 게시판에서 나올 만한 그런 통찰인 것 같아.
그리고 본인도 곤란해.
왜냐하면 계속 이쪽 일을 하는데 이쪽으로 넘어가야 돼.
그러니까 이쪽에서 더 위에가 있으면 상관이 없어.
그렇죠.
그런 거예요.
제가 경험이 없잖아요.
면에서 농사 좀 져봤고 한 1년 6개월 지낸 다음에는 계속 이제 홍보 2일만 하다 보니까.
그렇죠.
과장이 됐을 때 일을 잘 모르잖아요.
그러니까 나는.
회계든 민원 처리도 모르고 뭣도 모르니까 아무래도 그 리더십이랄까요.
직원들한테 지시도 못하고 또 직원들도 좀 신뢰가 없고 그런 게 있을 수밖에 없어서.
그런 것도 고민이 됐죠.
그리고 지자체 같은 경우는 6급이 거의 끝이에요 끝.
5급으로 퇴직합니다.
6급으로 퇴직하는 분도 있고.
나오실 때 6급이었잖아요.
네 그러니까 이미.
그래서 아까 졸업이라고 얘기했던 게.
이미 졸업반에다가 이미 관리직이었던 거예요.
지오 중무관을 데려오는 순간부터 저는 이미 사실은 조금 맞지 않는 옷을 입고 있는 걸 수도 있죠.
왜냐하면 저는 누구를 컨트롤하고 이런 것보다 제 장점은 그냥 저 혼자 막 박아서.
크리에이터를 쏟아내는 건데.
저 혼자 박아서 그냥 유튜브 만드는 게 저의 장점인데.
사실 팀장이 됐다는 거는 신경 쓸 것도 많거든요 좀 나름대로 관리직이다 보니까.
그런 면에서도 좀 저도 부담스럽긴 했죠 실제로.
이게 만약에 공기업이 아니고 사기업이었다면 위에 자리를 또 만들어 줬을 수도 있어요.
왜냐하면 전체 지자체의 유튜브를 같이 뭐 이렇게 같이 컨설팅도 하고 하는 역할을 점점 그렇죠.
근데 이게 보장이 안 돼요.
공기업이 있고 쉽지 않고 만들기가 특히 공기업이니까.
새로운 길이니까.
왜냐하면 또 세금으로 운영하다 보니까 이게 맘대로 안 되잖아요.
맞습니다.
그래서 그런 고민들을 좀 하셨을 것 같아요.
그래서 보도자료가 나오고 나였으면 어땠을까 해서 나온 생각이었어요.
제가 지금까지 말한 건.
오 역시 통찰이.
아 통찰이 아니고 그냥.
역시 이게 뭐가 있네요.
나였다면은 아 이게 더 이상 할 게 없는데.
그냥 간단하게 말하면.
그러면 이제 결국 나와야 되는데.
근데 금병에서 더 이상 올라갈 곳이 없으시잖아요 지금.
아 저요?
네.
맞아요.
그럼 어떻게.
그래서 요즘에 좀 고민 중이에요.
그래서 저는 요즘에 재미가 뭐냐면 같이 일하는 게 재밌어.
아 협업이.
사람을 뽑았잖아요.
처음에 나를 또 일을 도와주려고 오신 분들인데 일을 같이 하다 보니까 이 사람들하고 이제 뭐 물론 나는 이제 결과물에 대해서 막 그렇게 말을 하진 않지만 여기에 집중하지만 나도 하나의 부속품으로서 같이 한다는 게 재밌더라고요.
왜냐하면 제가 직장생활 안 해봤잖아요.
물론 직장생활이 즐거운 건 아니야.
왜냐하면 결정권이 없어요.
왜냐하면 결정권이 없을 때는.
근데 결정권이 있을 때는 생각보다는 훨씬 수월하죠.
그래서 이제 같이 하니까 재밌는 거예요.
그러니까 이런 생각을 하지.
계속 나한테 모든 거를 지원하는 거는 한 바구니에 담는 거잖아.
다른 바구니에 좀 담고 싶다.
이 분들하고도 같이 일을 계속 하려면.
아 맞아요.
그래서 이제 우리가 제작 쪽으로도 가야 되나.
그래서 요즘에 뭐 이렇게 녹화로 만드는 것도 좀 해보고 하는 거예요.
대세는 아니에요 이게 알고 보니까.
지금 좀 추세가 그렇게 좋지만은 않다고 하더라고요.
트렌드나 흐름에 좀 역으로 가는 경우이기도 해 지금 우리가.
그런 거 하는 거죠.
생산자랑 소비자랑 너무 이게 관점이 다른 거 같아요.
저도 이제 소비할 때 봤던 어떤 침착맨의 어떤 그런 방향성과
생산자로 보면 너무 이해가 가거든요.
우리는 항상 그런 거에 시달리잖아요.
다음에 뭐 하지? 뭘 해야 되지?
그런 거가 있는데 보는 사람들은 그냥 하던 거 하면 되지.
뭘 저렇게 고민하지가 있는 그게 너무 큰 거 같아요.
우리는 하던 것만 하는 게 우리도 이제 힘들고
우리가 재미를 못 느끼는데 보는 사람들은 더 못 느끼지 않으니까.
라는 항상 고민이 있는데 소비자들은 그거를 생각하지는 못하니까.
그거는 양쪽이 이해가 돼요.
하던 거를 해달라는 게 그 사람한테만 느껴지는 그 특유의 그게 있잖아요.
뭐 빠니모틀이 좀 약간 많이 얘기를 많이 들었을 거고
저도 되게 많이 들었던 부분이고.
그 옛날이 재밌었어.
그 옛날 그 특유의.
그래 비둘기도 먹고 이래야 되는데.
아니 나는 그 얘기를 인도 나와서부터 지금까지 7년 내에 듣고 있어.
허어어어.
나는 10년째 들어봤지.
계속 나와요.
나도 옛날에는 되게 듣기 싫었는데.
하스스톤이나 하지.
근데 그때 재미가 있어.
근데 그때 비슷하게 하스스톤을 계속 하던 사람들은 지금 이미 다 망했어.
그냥 하던 거 하는 사람들도 없어 지금.
근데 이유가 있다니까.
조금씩은 변해야 돼.
근데 그거를 아예 뭐만 하면은 조금만 새로운 거 하면은 하던 거 하나 하지.
뭐가 자꾸 이상한 거 하고 여행에 나가셔 이러면서.
그게 약간 시청자분들이 약간 오해하시는 게 있어. 소비자분들이.
그러니까 그것 있잖아요. 과자가 단종됐어.
아 나 그 과자 맛있었는데. 아 나 엄청 먹었는데 왜 단종됐어. 왜 단종됐겠어요.
안 팔리니까.
많이 사랑해주지 않으니까.
그 박명수 형님이 말씀해주신 거 있잖아.
그래.
되게 좋아했는데 없어졌어요. 사랑을 안 못 받았으니까 없어지는 거라고.
맞아 맞아.
심지어 재출시하는 경우 있어요. 계속 내달라고 해서.
다시 사라지는 경우 있어요.
무조건 사라져요.
실제 과자 그거 있어요. 재출시 다시 해가지고 너무 해달라고 해가지고.
사라지지.
근데 분명히 그 마음은 진짜야. 좋아하는 거. 근데 그 수가 매니아층만 있는 거야.
그렇죠 그렇죠. 적은 거예요. 너무 적은 거예요.
그래서 저는 옛날에 저도 막 그렇게 듣기 좋은 말은 아니에요.
제가 지금 생각을 정리한 게 매년 매년이 한정판이다.
맞아 맞아.
같은 소스에다 같이 넣어도 그게 안 나와.
나도 못해. 그러니까 그러니까 답답한 거야. 나도 그래서 답답했던 거였어.
본인도 안 돼요.
근데 문제는 소비자는 그거를 한정판으로 인지를 잘 못해.
쟤는 언제든지 할 수 있는 거라고 생각해.
왜 이거 또 안 해줘가 되는 거니까.
그러니까 뭐 예를 들어 제가 뭐 이렇게 똑같은 상황에서 다른 반응이 나오면은
탈모약을 먹고.
여성화가 됐다고 그래.
그런 얘기 있어요.
맞아 맞아.
아니요. 빨리 못 들으면 뭐 돈 맛을 들었다.
그런 얘기 있으니까.
돈 많이 벌고 변했다는 거.
다른 결과를 이유를 찾는 과정에서 자기가 아는 정보에서 찾다 보니까
이제 좀 그런 경우가 있거든요.
침추부를 예시를 들면은 오도바리 또 보고 싶으면 그때 그 영상 보면 돼요.
그렇죠.
근데 이제 아쉽죠. 더 보고 싶죠. 신지하게.
그 영상이 있는데. 그러니까 늘 하는 말이 고등학교 시절이 그립다고 해서
내가 교복을 입고 학교에 앉아있으면 내가 고등학교에 가고.
갈 수 있는 거 아니잖아.
그냥 난 그 흉내를 내고 있는 것 뿐이지.
그냥 지금 할 수 있는 게 있는 건데.
또 오도바리 얘기하니까 그립긴 한데.
어쩔 수 없지.
나도 그리워 사실.
나도 그립고 보는 사람도 그립고.
근데 뭐 어쩌겠어.
그러니까 이거.
건물 다시 허물고 갈 거냐고.
어?
재밌는 콘텐츠인데요.
허물자고요?
네.
저 다시 시작하겠습니다.
어떻게 만들었는데.
초심특집.
초심특집에서 채널도 새로파.
삭제.
사는 게 낙이 없습니다.
너무 잘 돼서 사는 게 낙이 없어요.
아 진짜요?
요새 재미없네요.
삭제하고.
저도 공무원 다시 들어가고.
아.
999로.
아 다시 지원.
네.
지원하는 것부터.
초심특집에서.
그러면 이제 채널을 팠는데 채널을 어떤 컨셉으로 할까를 좀 고민
을 했었을 것 같아요.
고민을 많이 했었죠.
천천히 시간을 두고 팔려고 했었 는데 제가 퇴직을 한다는 기자가
나왔는 바람에 이걸 너무 오래 안 하고 있을 수가 없는 거예요.
그래서 좀 약간 급하게 만들어서 기획을 많이 신경을 못 쓰고 만들
긴 했어요.
근데 그것도 빠니버틀에게 도움을 좀 받았습니다.
네.
그래서 제가 이 채널을 만들었 는데요.
되게 많이 도와줬네요.
초반에.
네.
전화가 전화가 많이 왔어요.
근데 저희가 사적으로 저렇게 막 전화를 하는 사이도 아니고.
그런 성격까지.
저도 원래 개인적으로 연락을 잘 안 하니까.
근데 연락이 와서.
어떤 유튜브를 할까 고민을 하던데.
뭘 고민을 하냐.
뭐 홍보 잘하니까 홍보면 해라.
그래가지고.
그때 만났지.
한 번 만났어요.
네.
근데 피겜 사람들 만났을 때 만나 가지고 얘기를 했었는데.
프사같은 것도 내가.
아.
하.
이.
여.
네.
이거는.
아.
한 같습니다.*
에.
두의.
네.
사실 이 안경이 여러분 이게 좀 두꺼워서
왜곡이 돼서 좀 그래 보이는 게 있습니다 더
실례지만 안경을 한번
아니 그니까 막 그렇게 돌아가진 않았어요
아니 이게 살짝 있는데 과장을 한 거지
그래야 더 너 같으니까
과장 안 하면 이게
그렇게 돌아가진 않아가지고
이거를 저기 미술용어로 적으라 그러죠?
데포르메? 과장하는 거?
데포르메 맞죠?
아니 데포르메라 한 거야 그냥
네 어쨌든 그림이 굉장히 극사실주의여서
처음에는 좀 별로였는데
보다 보니까 또 괜찮더라고요
이 그림은 그럼 요청을 해서 했다?
네 특별히 제작을 부탁드렸어요
근데 제가 그래가지고 처음에 맘에 안 들어서
귀여운 버전도 하나 만들어놓은 적이 있어요
이렇게 귀여운 버전
귀여운 버전인데
이것도 맘에 안 들어서
저는 처음에 안 쓸 줄 알았어요
보내니까 고마워 하고 연락이 없어가지고
안 쓸 줄 알았는데 너무 미안했다라는데
아니 표현을 잘한다
아니 빠니보틀이 진짜 잘해요
이런 걸 표현
괜찮았어요
표현력이 좋아
제가 그랬죠 그랬죠
만약에 네가 원하는 그런 깔끔하고
뭔가 그런 공무원분들이 좋아할 것 같은 스타일을 원하면
그냥 돈 주고 쓰는 게 낫다
아니면 AI를
돌리던가 했는데
결국 뭐 그때 당시엔 돈이 없었는지 쓰더라고요
그때 당시엔 돈이 또 없었고
그리고 또 이제 빨리 만들었어야 됐고
며칠만 기다리면 돈 생기는데
그리고 무엇보다
빠니보틀
몰랐어요 그때 몰랐고
빠니보틀이 해줬다는 거 자체가 또 의미가 있는 것 같아요
아 그렇지 스토리가 있으니까
제가 그 스토리를 생각하고 싶었어요
맞아 맞아
그 그림을 가지고 싶다기보다는
그 스토리 이야기를 가져가고 싶었어요
마치 살바도르 달리가
츄파춥스 그 패키지 디자인을 해줬다는 그 스토리
그게
루엣?
루엣 살루트 패키지 디자인 뭐 이런 느낌으로
그 스토리가 더 중요하다고 생각했어요
아 그렇구나
전에 청와대 얘기를 잠깐 했는데
그거 말고도 또 제의가 온 데가 있어요?
사기업이나 뭐
일단 연예수숙사
아 플레이어로
예
예능인으로서
네 그런데 그걸로 가면 이제
아예 이제 방송 쪽으로 가는 길이었던 것 같고
그거는 있었어요?
배우
배우?
아 왜
왜
아니 이건 전혀 아니고
예능이죠 예능인
여러 가지 뭐
일이 있었을 거예요
뭐 사실 청와대에서 오퍼가 온 건 사실이니까
그런 방법도 있고
뭐 연예계 방법
예능인도 방법이 있고
유튜버도 있고
뭐 이렇게 있는데 뭐 말렸다고 했잖아요
저는 솔직히 말하면은
청와대 가는 거 보다는 그냥
우리가 광대로 사는 게 낫지 않냐라는 식으로 얘기를 했었고
연예인 소속사는 제가 완전 말리진 않았는데
그 얘긴 했죠
그러니까 저는 지금 혼자 하고 있는데
너무 그게 맞고
혼자 하는 게 재밌기도 하고 잘 되고
근데 김선태라는 사람도 혼자 하는 게 더 어울릴 거라 생각했고
보는 사람들도 그럴 거라 생각했어요
그러니까 얘가 어디 들어가는 순간
또 그런 댓글 달릴 것 같아요
아 연예인 되려고 소속사 들어갔네 마네 이런 얘기도 갖고 왔고
공무원 버렸네 여기 가려고
미리 얘기 다 돼 있었네
근데 나는 그거보다 제일 신경 쓰이는 거는
소속사 들어가면 나눠 먹는 게 굉장히 아까워
그 이유 때문에 좀 많이 말렸던 것 같은데
소속사는 완전 말리진 않았어요
그러니까 뭐 너가 필요하면 들어가라
나눠 먹는 거 굉장히 배 아프더라고요
김선태님은 그 유튜브 같은데
이제 뭐 게스트로 출연하거나 하시면은
너무 재밌어 가지고
그냥 뭐 소속사에 들어가서
하셨어도 좋았을 것 같긴 한데
재능이 너무 많아요
그러니까 본인의 어떤 기획 능력들도 있기 때문에
그런 것까지 살리려면은
본인이 유튜브를 하는 게 좀 제가 생각해도 맞는 것 같네요
사실 뭐 정답이 나오긴 했어
백만이 나왔으니까
지금 와서 하는 말들은
완전 정답
사실은 지금 말하는 거는 뭐 그런데
근데 사실 우리 창민이 형님께서
저희 네이밍을 거의 굳게 만들어 주셨거든요
뭐요?
이거 모르실 거예요
원래는 제가 홍보맨이었거든요
맞아요 충주시 홍보맨
홍보맨인데 홍보맨이라는 타이틀을 가져가려고 했었어요 원래
그래서 홍보맨으로 계속 밀었거든요
근데 침착맨에 나오는데
침착맨 채널에 충주맨이라고 딱 뜬 거예요
박혔어 썸네일이
그때부터는 다 충주맨이 됐어요
그니까 그 전부터도 충주맨 수위가 좀 많긴 했거든요
있었어요
반반
충주맨이라고 부르는 사람들이 또 있었어요
반반이었어요 홍보맨 충주맨이 반반이었는데
침착맨에서 충주맨으로 딱 찍으니까
그때부터는 충주맨이 됐어요
모든 언론과 모든
유튜브의 신이 그렇게 하라면 해야지
그렇죠 그러니까 어떻게 보면 게시를 받은 거죠
반대로 해야죠
자네 이름은 이제부터 홍보맨이야
너는 이제부터 충주맨이요?
근데 저는 이제 유튜브에 잡신
유튜브에 제우스가 있는데
제우스가 그림을 그려주면 써야지
그렇죠 써야죠
제우스가 두 개나 그려줬어 심지어
야 이 둘 중에 하나 골라 그러면 무조건 써야 되는 거예요
근데 그런 생각도 했어요
이런 신 같은 분이 그려줬는데
둘 다 안 쓴다?
야 그분은 벼락 맞아
저는 그림을 바친 거예요
그러니까 이렇게 바친 거예요 그림을
우리 라이징 신에게 신신
아 신의 신
아니
그림을
다 네네네게
그렇죠 그래서 그게 굉장히
새로운 세계의 신에게
그래서 굉장히 두 분의 도움을 많이 받았다
진짜로 그랬습니다
근데 홍보가 실제로 홍보 요청이 되게 많이 왔어요?
요청 많이 왔죠 많이 왔는데
마비가 될 정도로?
처음에는 진짜 한 300개 이상 온 것 같아요
저희가 이제 그거를 다 할 수가 없고
잘 아시겠지만 이제 뭔가
장난도 있고 물론
장난 뭐 있어?
아니 막 욕까지 쓰는 경우도 있어요
막 욕 욕도 있고
그러니까 낚시도 있고
아니 똥 보내는 애들이 있어
똥 사진을 보내
아
그리고 그 새끼 아직도 있어?
그럼 그거를 이제 막 300개나 왔는데
고른 기준이 뭐예요?
처음이 되게 좀 고민됐을 것 같아
우리은행이 처음이었죠?
나온 건 우리은행이 처음이었어요
근데 제가 뭘 할지를 모르잖아요 저도
채널을 만들었는데
제가 홍보를 뭐 어떤 식으로 할지 모르니까
그거부터 생각을 했죠
이 회사랑 나랑 뭘 했을 때 맞을까
약간 이거부터 생각을 했고
그래서 약간 옛날에 저희가 막
동아일보도 가고 대검찰청도 가고 막 했던
그런 거를 같이 해야 되겠다
라고 생각해서 그걸 반영해서 봤을 때
우리은행이 제일 괜찮아 보여요 그때 당시는
그래서 하게 됐습니다
그 다음 그 다음 다 이유가 있는 거예요 뭔가?
근데 그 다음부터는 사실
저희 직원분이 많이 컨트롤해 주셔서
직원은 어떻게 하다가 이제
저희 직원분께서는 경력이 없으세요
다른 일을 하셨다가?
아니요 일도 안 해보셨던
그럼 첫 직장이에요?
네 첫 직장
신입
네 첫 직장이시고
제가 좀 아는 교수님한테 추천을 받아가지고
왜냐면 제가 그때 너무 급해가지고
진짜 당일에 바로 일할 사람이 필요했어요
그 인력 사무소에서 바로 그래야 될 판이었기 때문에
조건이 오늘부터 일하실 수?
네 지금 지금
그래서 면접을 카페에서 했거든요
하고서 바로 일터로 이동했어요
그대로 픽업해서
자 이제 됐죠? 가시면 됩니다 하고
그분도 아 예 뭐 하죠 뭐
떨떠름하셨는데
그래도 이제 제가 뭐 가자고 하니까
오케이 네 알겠습니다 하고서 이제 가서
원래 그런 건가 하시면서
처음이 처음이시니까
그래도 얼굴 팔렸으니까 그러죠 얼굴 안 팔렸잖아요
따라가기 쉽지 않을까
쉽지 않죠
근데 이게 딱 하니까 맞아요 좀?
되게 열심히 해주세요 진짜로
저도 옛날에 침체부 편집자 지원했다 떨어졌어요 공채
근데 근데 그 진짜 메일을 다 주시더라고요
근데 저는 그게
명절마다 나한테 선물 보내야겠다
내가 이렇게 안 해가지고 지금
그러네
왜 안 보내?
감동이었던 게 내가 이거 막상 해보니까
나는 뽑지 않는데 지원이 많이 들어와
그걸 일일이 답장하기가 되게 어려워
근데 그때 직접적으로 영상 잘 봤고 좋은데
뭐 이렇게 하시면서 뭐 아쉽습니다 하면서 이제
다음 기회에 한번 또 오시고 싶네요 이런 식으로
그래서 그때 되게 원래 팬이었지만
또 메일을 다 주셔가지고
내가 직접 그 상황 돼보니까
그렇게 일일이 답장하는 게 정말 어려운 일이다
난 안 하거든 잘
어렵지
대단했다 역시 유튜브의 신
역시 인성까지
하도파도 미담만 나올 수밖에 없네요
유비시네요 역시 유비
인품이 있으시고
귀도 좀 커지신 거 같아요 초창기보다는
자꾸 늘어져요
탄력이 없어졌어
왜 늘어지는가 해서 나 이렇게 옛날에
늙은 노승 보면 귀가 여기까지 있잖아
나 여기까지 했는데 탄력이 없어져
그러게 계속 보니까 조금 늘어난 거 같기도 하고
우리 아빠 여기 있어
구멍이 있는데 늘리시는 거 아니죠?
이렇게 무거워 달아가지고
인품 위에서 인품 늘려야지?
일부러 이렇게 원심도 쪄가지고
털렁터렁 거리게
덤보 덤보처럼
근데 이제 법인 만드셨다고 했잖아요
근데 이제 개인 사업자로 해도 되는데
법인으로 딱 하는 이유도 있어요?
그게 더 낫다고 하더라고요 깔끔하다고 하더라고요
사람을 고용하고 할 때도
고용할 때도 그렇고 뭔가 더 체계를 갖추고 싶어서
그래서 처음에는 사무실 구하는 것도 사실 약간 도박이었어요
사실 집에서 해도 되는 건데
원래 집에서 하는 경우도 있긴 하거든요
근데 법인은 또 이제 아예 나와서 사무실에 있어야 돼가지고
제가 충주 오피스텔이라고 검색하면 두 개밖에 없어요
그 중에 하나를 해서
근데 거의 원룸입니다
원래 애플도 차고에서 시작했잖아
잡기 시작해서 또 신화가 만들어지는 거니까
나중에 그 자서전 쓸 때 써야 되니까
지금 사무실에서 일하는 거 사진은 한 장 찍어놔
에마잔 제프 베조스가 일하는 거 있잖아요
한 장은 찍어놔야겠네요?
한 장은 찍어놔요
알겠습니다
그래도 직원분 한 분 있다면서요?
지금 있죠
네 찍어달라고 하세요
알겠습니다
좋은 팁이네요
창립 멤버가 되는 거네요 그러면
스티브 잡지랑 저희처럼
워지니아?
워지니아처럼
그럼 이 잡지 시기 맞나요?
발기인이요?
그렇지 발기인 맞지
같이 그거 하는 거 아니야?
몰래요
아니 몰란 게 아니고
고은석이야 미친놈아
발기인이에요?
그 세운
아 세운 사람?
아 세운 사람이요? 이상한 뜻인가 봐
아니 그게 아니고
회사를 세운 사람
세운 사람
너 알면서 왜 그래
그러면 이제 지금 홍보를 하잖아요
짧은 그 영상으로
다른 것도 생각하는 게 있어요?
다른 시리즈나 간략하게 뭐 단편으로 할 만한 것들이나
보니까 우라카이가 중요하더라고요
왜냐면 검증된 포맷이 또 중요하지 않겠습니까?
일단은 저희가 기업 탐방을 가는 거는 워크맨
워크맨을 좀 이제 우라카이를 하면 될 것 같고요
워크맨
오마주라고 하자 오마주
네 뺏기 오마주를 하면 될 것 같아요
그리고 지자체 여행을 간다
뭘 뺏겨요?
그러면 바로 이제 빠니보트를 뺏기면 되겠죠
아 인물 인터뷰를 해
그럼 누구를 뺏기면 되죠?
침터뷰
여기 있지 않습니까?
아
그러니까 이렇게 다 좋은 점만 이렇게 뽑아다가
카피를 해보는 거죠
그러다가 반응이 터지는 쪽으로
조금 빈도를 높이고
그러면 또 이제
아 옛날에 심창맨 따라하는 게 좋았는데
이러면 이제 그런 얘기들이 나오는 거죠
아 빠니보틀처럼 여행 가는 게 좋았는데
뭐 이런 식으로
그러다 하나 이제 걸리면 또 하는 거고
쭉 가는 거죠 그러면
아예 그걸로만
나도 외국 유튜버 여행 유튜버 우라카이라서
그렇지 뭐 다 그렇게 하는 거지
저도 그렇지 뭐
어? 누구를 혹시?
사실 그냥 한 말이었어요
저희 귀찮아서 자료 조사를 안 했어요
뭐 따가라니까요
제가 했겠죠 지나가다 뭐
네터맨 쇼? 뭐 이런 거 봤겠지 뭐
호난 오브라이언 뭐 이런 거 봤겠지
사람은 생각하는 게 다 거기서 거기 더라고
해보고 그런 거겠지
그래서 이렇게 잘 되는 거를 많이 참고하면
도움이 될 것 같습니다
그러면 이제 본인이 결국은 뭐 이렇게
여기저기 뛰고 뭐 토크하고 뭐
보통 그런 거를 생각한 거고
막 뭔가 막 확 기획이 들어간 거는
아직은 생각을 안 하고 있어요?
그렇게 말씀하시니까 또 근본이 없는
아니 아니 그게 왜냐면
혼자 할 때는 자연스럽게 그렇게 하고
네
악연이 아 이런 거는 한번 해보고 싶다라는 거
있을 수도 있어가지고
그래서 이제 그거를 진행을 하다가
약간 얻어 걸리면 그쪽으로 좀 심화를 할 생각이긴 합니다
아예 어? 의외로 이게 잘 됐어
그러면 이쪽으로 이제 파가지고
좀 특이한 쪽으로 가면 되고
그러니까 좀 덧붙이는 식으로
지금 나왔거든요
뭐 줏소 후속작으로 줏공무원 이런 거
웹드가 나왔는데
실제로 제가 물어본 적은 있어요
아 맞아 맞아
어 웹드 공무원 컨셉으로 하라 하면은
재밌을 것 같다라는 얘기가 이제 나왔었는데
저도 맨날 그런 생각만 하고
실제 10개 생각하면은 실행이 옮기니까
한 2개밖에 안 돼서
그거 할까 저거 할까 하다가
이제 같이 했던 게 제체되어서
뭐 빠까질 이런 거 했었고
드라마 그리고 돈이 좀 안 돼가지고
많은 분들이 오해하시는 게 막
조쪼스로 되게 엄청 큰 돈을 버신 줄 아는데
안 벌지는 않았는데
그렇게 막 엄청 벌지는 않았고
웹드라마계의 장항준 감독이잖아요
네?
너무 잘 돼가지고
아 근데 약간 신화적이죠
너무 신화적인
무슨 소리 하는 거죠
기념비적인
사실 이쪽 업계에서 일을 했던 사람도 아닌데
갑자기 혜성같이 등장해서
리얼리티를 좀 추구하는
아 그니까
극을 만들었죠
아 제가 근데
명작이죠 명작
저는 솔직히 말하면
조쪼스 끝난 직후에는
제가 진짜 천재인 줄 알았어요
진짜로
근데 이제 그 이후에
두 개를 말아먹고 나서는
아 그냥 아다리가 좋았구나
그냥 시기가 좋았다
코로나 때 시기가 좋아서 그런 거고
많이 이제 겸손해졌죠
그니까 약간 뭐 시트콤이나 어떤 뭐
재밌는 웹드라마나
요거를 만들고 싶은기보다는
계속 새로운 게 하고 싶은 거예요?
맞아요
저는 이것저것 다 건드려보는 걸 좀 좋아해서
지금도 여행을 좋아하긴 하지만
너무 오래 하면은
옛날만큼의 느낌도 없고
사람들은 계속 옛날 느낌을 원하는데
이미 나는 다르고 다른
십몇 년째 여행을 하고 있는데
그게 안 나오잖아요 근데
새로운 걸 하면 너무 재밌는 거예요
뭐 드라마를 만든다던가
아니면 뭐 서바이벌 제작한다던가
뭐 나가면 재밌고 아니면은 뭐
요즘에 뭐 안 해본 것들 계속 하는 게 재밌어가지고
공무원도 사실은
원래 할까 하다가
약간 조쪼스랑 비슷할 것 같아서
그니까 생각할 땐 막 재밌지
근데 막상 시나리오 쓰려고 그러면은
갑자기 흥미가 뚝 떨어져요
흥미가 뚝 떨어져요
나랑 완전히 성향이 대척점이었어요
나는 익숙한 걸 하려고 그래
그리고
새로운 것도 하잖아요 이렇게 하잖아요
익숙한 걸 하다가
더 이상 할 게 없으면 이제
하나 뀨옥 해서 이렇게 붙이는 거예요
아 이게 튀어나가는구나
꽉 차야지 알이 꽉 차야지
이만큼
여드름처럼 뿔룩 나오는 거야 이게
나는 그렇게 해가지고 조금씩 하는 거고
여기는 계속 이렇게 이렇게
흥미가 계속 바뀌어서 하다가
요걸 또 하고 요것도 하고
그래서 이렇게 딱딱딱 해가지고 약간
좀 훈는 스타일이에요 저는
어 그리고 이게 연결이 이렇게 약간 돼있는
그니까 구조가 조금 달라
어떻게 보면 저는 그것도
여행의 일환이라고 보는 느낌이거든요
안 해본 거 하는 거니까
도전해볼까요?
도전 정신이 되게 있는 거 같아
이걸 봐도 잘 안 되네
아 뭐 말 좀 아까 이런 느낌으로
앞으로의 뭐 계획 같은 것도 있습니까?
유튜브 말고
아예 유튜브를 넘어선
저는 사실
얼마나 할지 모르겠어요
그러시는 분들이 있거든요 가끔
아 재미없다
공무원 나와가지고 이거 하더니 역시
역시 알만하다 너무 별로다
이런 얘기를 많이 해요
그러면서 막 말씀해 주시는 게
갑자기 철학이 안 느껴져
네 그러면서 막 이래요 막
어 이거 뭐 1년밖에 못 가겠네
저는 그걸 덕담이라고 생각합니다
1년이나
1년이나 간다고?
아 덕담이야
1년이나 한다고?
본인조차도 1년을 생각 못하고
저도 저도 1년을 생각 안 하고 있는데
1년이나 덕담을
저를 너무 위해 주시는 거예요
그래서 그분들에게 너무 감동이었고
1년만 한번 버텨보자
이런 게 계획입니다
그럼 댓글에 1년 본다 이러면
아 너무 감사합니다
감사합니다 하면서
진짜 1년이 가는지를 한번 저도 체크를 해보고 싶고
그럼 막 뭐 지금 막 거창하게
막 이것도 해보고 싶고
저것도 해보고 싶고 이런 단계가 아니고
일단 생존하자
아 그렇죠 지금은
지금은 일단 이 시장에서 살아남아야 되니까요
지금은 그거에 좀 집중을 해야 될 것 같고
1년이면 저는 생존했다고 생각하면 돼요 거의
집에서 이거 그만둔다고 했을 때
의견은 어땠어요?
전부 다 반대했고
아 반대가 있었어
모든 지인 모든 분들 다 반대했어요
어?
주변
진짜?
6급이니까
이게 되게 되게 높은 거거든요
여기서는 그래도 나름 괜찮기 때문에
하라고 했던 거는 빠니보틀이랑
그나마 와이프 차라리
오
이분은 들깨잖아
그쵸
들깨니까 고기 맛을 몰라
늑구예요 늑구
늑구이기 때문에
돌아다니거든요 항상
몰라 원래 없었던 거거든
6급이라는 게 뭔지도 몰라
그니까 뭔지 몰랐을 거야
6급 한번 보러 가야겠다
6급의 가치를 몰라 이분은
6급 잡힌 거 알지?
어 잡혔어
아무튼 아내분은 굳이 따지면
그래 하고 싶은 대로 해라 이 느낌이었어요?
네 하고 싶은 대로
네가 정 그러면
나는 그렇게 강추는 안 해
그렇죠 강추는 아닌데
네가 하려면 해라 약간 이런
그래도 허용적인 표현이었고
부모님부터 장인장모님 친구들
동료들 거의 다 반대를 했고
대책 없이 지금 왜 그렇게 하려고 하냐
이런 얘기가 되게 많았었고
저도 웹툰 작가 할 때 처음에 한
3개월 정도 집에서 했었거든요
그때 결혼 안 했을 때니까
부모님이 야 언제까지 할 거야
그래서 아니 뭐 한도까지 하는 거지
너 1년까지만 해
오 그래도 많이 주셨네요
1년 본다 집착맨 1년 본다
엄마가
너 웹툰 1년 본다
지금 돌이켜 보니까 그런 건데
아프게 집에서 낳았네
그때 당시 약간 알바 같은 느낌이었어
네가 재밌으니까 하는데
임시지
이게 뭐 인생의 경력으로 되는 건 아니니까
누려 누리는데
이거는 계속 누릴 순 없는 거야 라고 인식을 하신 거야
부모님들은 아무래도 좀 기존에 있던 거에
너무 잘 아시니까 반대를 하실 수밖에 없는 거고
그때 세상이랑 지금 세상이랑 너무 달라져가지고
앞으로는 우리가 예측이 안 되잖아요 이제는
AI도 막 나오고 해서 뭐가 잘 될지 모르고
다 불안해
맞아 맞아
오히려 또 그런 거 같아요
공무원 세계가 또 그런 거 있잖아요
실적 평가하는 거 해가지고
그만두는 경우는 없는데
불이익 같은 게 있지 않아요?
불이익은 따로 없고
굳이 말하자면 성과급이 존재하긴 합니다
그러니까 S, A, B 이렇게 성과급이 안 있는데
근데 짬순이죠
그 연말에 그런 걸 하잖아요 인사평가
실제로 그거 인사평가로 연봉이 책정이 뭐
다이나믹하게 결정되는 건 아니지만
어느 정도 그게 들어간다고 있는데
공무원은 그런 게 없어?
그거는 전혀 없다고 봐야죠
그러니까 금평이 있고 승진에 연동이 되긴 하는데
금평도 짬으로 줄 수밖에 없어요
왜냐면 몇 년 후배를 더 위에 주기가
왜냐면 계속 같이 볼 사람들이잖아요
윗분들 입장에서도 아닌 경우도 있는데
대부분은 좀 특별한 문제 없으면 그냥 같이
그냥 좋게 좋게 하자는 거죠
전반적인 부분은 좋게 좋게
결국 인간관계 보고 가는 거야
이 사람하고 그냥 껄끄럽지 않고
그냥 내가 지금 다니는 게 좋은 환경 딱 구축하고
그냥 왔다 갔다 하면서 일하는 거고
그러니까 이제 높은 가치가 되는 거지 덕목이 되는 거지
그게 이제 전체 분이긴 한데
근데 개중에서도 진짜 열심히 하는 분들도 있고
그런 분들이 또 인정받아서 좋은 부서 가는 경우도 꽤 있고
아니면 그런 사람들이 약간 벽을 느껴서
어렵게 들어가서 다시 나가는 경우도 있고
나가는 경우도 있고
다른 사기업 다녀본 적 있어요?
사기업은 안 다녔습니다
그렇게 해서 그만뒀어요 예를 들어
그래서 사기업이 어렵게 해서 들어왔어요
어? 별반 다른 게 없네
그럴 수도 있지
사기업이라고 생각해서 들어왔는데
졸라 답답하네 여기도 티 졸라 안 나고
나는 이런 경우가 많대요
저도 들었어요
그러니까 이게 공무원만 겪어봐서 그런 걸 수도 있고
이게 사실 공무원의 특성인지
조직사회의 특성인지를 사실 구분을 못 하는 그런 걸 수도 있어요
사기업도 비슷할 수도 있을 것 같아요
오히려 더 심한 부분도 있다고
상사가 공 가르치는 것도 되게 많다고 들었고
제가 겪어보진 않았는데 그런 것도 많고
저도 뭐 엄청 오래 다니진 않아 가지고
잘 모르지만 있을 거예요
혹시 금병형은 어떻게?
여기는
조금 공무원 같은 마인드가 좀 있나요?
아니면 성과를 어떻게 혹시 평가하시는지?
여기는
굉장히 소잖아요 소기업이잖아요
그러니까 조직원들이 서로를 다 알아요
어떻게 보면 팀이잖아요
상호 감시를 하는 건가요?
아 북한이네 북한
가구별로
북한이네
별 가구를 해서
5호 5호 5호 5호
5호씩 딱 묶어가지고
옷도둑 가게?
네
그렇게 하고 저는 감사하게도
이거는 제가 참 혜택을 보는 부분이라고 보는데
저를 보고 오신 분들이 많아서
동기부여가 하나 플러스 되는 느낌이에요
약간 패시브에 살짝 보너스?
롤로 치면
그러니까 이걸 했을 때
좀 더 의욕적으로 하시는 분들이 좀 많은 거 같아요
내가 열심히 하면은 내가 좋아하는 채널이
조금 더 발전하고 성장한다가
생각보다 굉장히 큰 동기라서
사실 그게 뭐 대기업이나 큰 조직에서
그런 시스템을 만든 이유는
가만히 냅두면 그게 안 되니까 그런 건데
알아서 되니까 그거에 대한 그건 없어
근데 물론 분기마다 평가는 들어가요
하긴 하는군요
그리고 이제 그것만 데이터만 보면 안 되니까 우리는 이제
오호로 이제 다 감시를 하니까
옆에서 봤을 때
이분이 어느 정도로 좀 적극성을 띄웠느냐도
조금 참고도 하고
그러니까 어떻게 보면 신앙심을 테스트하는 거네요
아 그쵸
제가 봤을 때 그 외에 일본 만화 중에
회사를 너무 좋아하는 사람이라 가지고
주말에도 회사를 가고 싶어서
출퇴근을 하는 사람이 있어
회사 덕진하는 거
그 정도의 사람들이 와 있는 곳이 내가 봤을 땐 금명형이다
내가 금명형에 와 있다니
한미 무대에 와 있다니
아 근데 진짜 약간 비슷해
그 정도까지는 아니더라도
와서 내가 한 게 여기에 이제 해가지고
실환도 되고 되고 뭐 이런 게 이제 재밌다
회사 덕진
그런 개념이 좀 있어요
그럴 수 있을 거 같아요
그러니까 나도 약간 이제 애착이 가니까
아 우리랑 뭘 할 수 있을까를 계속 고민하는 거 같기도 하고
소규모니까 가능한 거 같아요
이게 커지면 서로가 서로 얼굴을 이제 못 보면서
감시를 못 하게 되면
이게 좀 힘들 거 같아
11조도 잘 안 거치고
네 11조도 잘 안 거치고
정신부장도 잘 안 되고
정신부장이요?
아 부장해야 돼
저번에 소개팅 했잖아요
혹시 그 통일교회 결혼식을 따라 하는 건가요 그것도?
아 영어 결혼식?
그니까 느낌이 비슷하네
합동 결혼식이네 보니까
통일교회에서 막 삼천 쌍
근데 그 합동 결혼식을 중계까지 하잖아
중계 실시간
저는 이제 그 통천이 제시를 해서 중계만 맡은 거지
통일교회 합동 결혼식은 어떻게 진행되는지 아세요?
잘 몰라요
뭐 다 같이 모여서 하는 것만 알고 있어요
무조건 랜덤이에요
랜덤이라고요?
그게 어떤 거냐면
50살 아저씨랑 20대 외국인 여자가 막 이렇게 서있고
어떤 막 아줌마 할머니가 막 여기 서있고
옆에 청년이 서있고 막 그래요
약간 가차? 가차인가?
그냥 롤 그거야
롤 큐야
누가 내 팀이 될지 모르는 거야
나도 이게 정확한 게 아닌데
몇 번 리롤이 있어요
아 리롤이구나
두 번인가 두 번인가 있어
아 이거는 있어야지
그러니까 이거는 있어
닷지는 해야지
그러니까 활발하냐
활발하게 리롤을
주사위 주사위
정확한 건 아니야 나도 주어 들은 거야
맞아 맞아
통일교회 알 순 없잖아
리롤이 한 두 번 있다고 들었어
리롤
그거 웃기겠다
잠시만
만났는데
둘 다 맘에 안 들어
근데 내 주사위 쓰기 싫어
아 유도해
유도해
얘가 맘에 안 들면
아 제가 주사위 굴려주면 더 좋을 거 같은데
트롤 짓 하고
그러다가 둘 다
롤 닷지 유도자잖아
영주까지 생각하는데
닷지를 못 해가지고
그냥 게임 들어가면 개 웃기겠다
둘 다 서로
니가 해 하다가
그럴 확률이 굉장히 높아
둘 다 주사위 안 굴렸어
내 거 쓰기 싫어가지고
기다리다가
심지어 이런 경우도 있어
다 썼어
한 번만 해줘
한 번 해줘
이 사람은 하나 남았어
안 해주려고 그래
왜냐면 이 사람은
하나 남았어
하나만 이거 쓰면
다음에 못하자니까
웬만하면 안 쓰고 싶다냐
거기서 오는 이 심리전
이거는 카이즈잖아
피해 게임이야
아 진짜 웃기다
심리전
그래가지고 완벽한 심리전을 짜가지고
이 사람이 무조건
하나 남은 걸 쓸 수밖에 없게끔
다 짰어 카이즈처럼
딱 들어갔어 근데
알고 보니까 이 사람 다 써가지고
선택권이 없었던 거야
쭉 하는 거
없지 졸려
전 없어
어 없으죠
집이 기독교 천주교예요
부모님 뭐
처가
전 유튜브에서는 뭐
아 여기
저희는 이제 유튜브에 시를 모시고 있으니까
아냐 아냐
이
현신이시죠 살아있는
생불
해탈하셨으니까
여기가 본거지
본거지
사실
생불이라면 인도 사람일 텐데
인도 사람 느낌은 좀 있긴 해요 근데
어 그래 조금
알파고님이 보시더니
아 좀 우리 동네 와도 될 거 같아
조금 그랬어